as parents go online to find last-minute
holiday gifts for their kids
we found some toys sold on Amazon could
be dangerous for your children online
shopping is skyrocketing it is expected
to soar to nearly listen look at that
number 144 billion dollars with a B this
holiday season we bought several toys on
Amazon and put them through basic safety
tests at an accredited lab the results
we could say are concerning Errol
Barnett is here with more on that story
good morning to you ro what do you think
parents need to know
hey there good morning well look things
are cheap online for a reason children's
toys sold in the u.s. are subject to
more than 100 tests and requirements to
protect kids from things like choking
hazards or misleading age
recommendations that's the good news
however we found some items sold online
that don't meet those standards and
certainly could put your kids at risk
Erin mu Turek founder of crazy Aaron's
Thinking Putty says in a business
dedicated to fun dealing with apparent
knock-offs
sold online is anything but it's sort of
like a game of whack-a-mole
you hit one down and another one comes
right back up Mew Turek says after he
put his products up for sale on Amazon
back in 2010 similar products quickly
followed this is all of the different
product that we found in the market that
looks surprisingly like crazy Aaron's
Thinking Putty why does this make you so
angry every single one of our unique
products goes through a litany of safety
testing when someone's knocking off a
product they're not spending that money
it's very difficult for customers to
know did this product actually pass
these tests his biggest concern cheaper
versions of his magnetic putty which use
magnets that are not in line with US
safety standards the magnet needs to be
of a certain size that it is
extraordinarily unlikely that it could
be swallowed and also limitations in
regards to how strong a magnet can be
safety experts use this tube to check if
pieces are small enough to create a
choking hazard while muta ryx magnets
are too big to fit inside doesn't fit
this magnet from a product purchased
online fits right on the other major
concern is the magnet strength
Becca Mondas with the toy association a
trade group representing US businesses
that design produce license and deliver
toys small magnets if they're swallowed
they can really just cause a lot of
problems in a child's digestive system a
four year old Wisconsin boy reportedly
had to have part of his intestines
removed after swallowing small magnets
from a different knockoff toy our
children should not be the testing
grounds for the toys we purchase for
products from third-party sellers
through Amazon and had them tested at an
accredited lab according to that lab all
four samples failed safety tests this
wooden jigsaw puzzle marketed for kids
as young as one included small objects
that could be a choking hazard these
trucks broke during testing exposing
sharp points these flashing LED rings
separated exposing the battery component
and the magnetic putty once advertised
as Amazon's choice contained a hazardous
magnet stronger than what US safety
standards allow in a statement Amazon
wrote quote safety is a top priority we
require all products offered in our
store to comply with applicable laws and
regulations and have developed
industry-leading tools to prevent unsafe
products in our stores they go on to say
that when a concern arises they move
quickly to protect customers and work
directly with sellers brands and
government agencies if a deal seems too
good to be true it probably is the toy
Association says parents shopping online
should look for reputable sellers they
know dig into the product listing a
little bit deeper look at their reviews
and look at the product description for
typos and grammatical errors but Muta
ryx says online retailers must do more
to keep kids safe I think we're doing
everything that we can do from our
perspective but as long as these
products continue to just ship in and
this whack-a-mole game of sellers coming
and going goes on these products will
remain on the market now we tried
contacting the four companies who sell
the toys we tested but only
one got back to us and that's the one
who sold those toy trucks it told us it
products meet safety standards and
passed us safety tests but get this from
a lab in China but it did not test for
all of the defects that we found in our
lab tests and an Amazon spokesperson
told us just last night that it is now
investigating all of the products in
question very interesting and worrying
as well if you're a parent who thinks
that they have purchased one of these
counterfeit and potentially dangerous
items what do they do well good news is
you know be alert about this so you want
to check you can check the return policy
you might be able to get your money back
certainly alert the platform like Amazon
or other third party seller and most
importantly you can report this stuff to
the Consumer Product Safety Commission
if this thing you think is dangerous
they can potentially investigate but
there was a recent poll that found that
a third of parents actually would
consider buying the knockoff version
even if it's unavailable elsewhere to
make a kid's right before the holidays
yeah you can see why Erin's have said
his company and he do all the work and
another benefit from the work that he's
put in writing stuff that deep discount
yeah very reasonable yeah all right
thank you very much